so how do you get views on youtube in
today's episode i'm going to be sharing
three tips with you and then i have a
special guest rob from vid iq who's
going to help me break down some free
channel reviews right here on the show
let's jump into tip number one of how to
get views on youtube
and that is actually to
uh tip number one is to choose a
specific niche tip number one is to
choose a specific niche and this is
really important when you're just
getting started on youtube because you
want to give youtube as much information
about who you are and how you can help
people so when you think about what
things you're passionate about or maybe
the career that you're in that you want
to transfer into the online space you
want to really identify what niche are
you in and i hear you you're like
heather i'm into a lot of things and
that's fine but on youtube you really
want to be able to let youtube
categorize you so they can show your
videos to the right person all right tip
number two is you want to answer
specific questions when it comes to what
videos you should be making how you
should be going about getting more views
in this year and beyond you want to
think about answering specific questions
one question one video what's great
about that is that if you have returning
viewers if you have people who are
struggling with something and they're
typing in the youtube search bar you'll
actually have the opportunity to come up
and be in front of those new potential
subscribers so in order to grow your
channel get more views if you answer
specific questions you'll have a better
opportunity you'll have more hooks in
the ocean to be able to reach your
people and get your videos into their
feed and tip number three is that you
want to make a video about an
influential person in your niche now
here's a great strategy for actually
getting uh what's called fame jacking or
influence jacking where you're going to
take someone who is influential a
celebrity or someone in your space that
um would get a lot of attention here's
an example let's say you're a cooking
channel
and gordon ramsay has a new recipe or
has a viral recipe that he's doing on
youtube maybe you want to interpret that
into your own way and you're going to
use the fame of gordon ramsay on your
channel as well this is a great way
where you can actually slide into the
suggested feed of youtube so that people
can discover your videos as well well i
hope that helped get you some views this
year we're going to jump into from some
free channel reviews but before we do i
want to welcome you to the youtube made
simple show
[Music]
my name is heather torres and i am the
host of the show for you today here on
the think media podcast channel make
sure you're hitting the red button the
subscribe button if you would like to be
a part of our think media community here
where we're helping you grow your
business as well as your youtube channel
so that you can make a bigger impact in
the world and i'm so excited today
because i'm joined by my friend rob and
fellow youtuber uh over at vid iq now if
you haven't met rob yet you need to uh
he is the go-to guy when it comes to all
things vid iq he started his own channel
transferred actually over to helping
vidiq grow their youtube channel and get
this they just passed a million
subscribers i'm so excited to celebrate
with him rob how you doing today
hello everybody yes yes
oh wow no i'm covering my head's
covering it there you go wow
oh such wonderful placement thank you
ikea for making shields that do not fit
play buttons uh i just want to say
heather what an awesome way to introduce
a live stream none of the intro rubbish
or anything just get straight into it
three knowledge bombs and then we'll
kick it off fantastic way to start the
livestream and thank you for having me
on um think media once again
i am so excited every time you're here
rob i love the knowledge that you bring
to this community you know i i think
that one of the best things about being
a part of the youtube community is the
amount of community and support that is
out there you know this is this is what
we get to do for a living we get to help
other people learn how to grow on
youtube and you have so much knowledge
and insight from being a part of the vid
iq family for so long and really diving
into the ways that they help creators
and i think if you've not already
subscribed to vidiq make sure you
subscribe to their channel as well well
rob let's get into our first channel
review and here's what we're gonna do if
you would like to have your channel
reviewed today put in the comments i
want a review and also a specific
question that you would like us to
answer about your channel this helps us
to be able to dive into maybe if you
want a tip on your thumbnails or if you
have questions about the video content
that you're making the titling or if you
just want an overall you know how's this
channel doing let us know and then if
you are doing a super chat of over
twenty dollars you will actually move to
the front of the line we're gonna kick
it off with a free review today and
rob's gonna start and then i'm gonna
pick the next person
okay uh so the first channel that we
have on the list is uh michael
ferberger who just on first impressions
i think one of the things that's very
important for all youtube channels
is to try and tell the potential viewer
if they're in the right place as soon as
possible and with your channel banner
and some of the thumbnails i kind of get
the idea that this is maybe a comedy
entertainment place on youtube so i
think the messaging there is a fairly
strong the question michael asks here is
a very simple one and many creators come
into youtube with this question along
with how to get more subscribers
michael's question is how do i get more
views and
as always it's a lot more nuanced and
complicated than that and i think you
just need to retweet your question a
little bit more to
how do i build an audience because one
of the challenges michael you have in
your space as entertainment
is
what's the through line if somebody
enjoys one piece of your content what's
going to bring them back for the next
piece of content and as i look at your
thumbnails i see that you're jumping
through many different uh themes and
topics we've got about to the future one
here retro 80s music okay those two
themes kind of have some connections but
then judge judy talks to tai lopez i
don't know how that links to a previous
video your latest video forrest gump
auditions for american idol okay y'all
taking two
popular well-known uh
i guess tv series and film and trying to
merge them together
but
forrest gump came out all was it 20
years ago i can't remember the last time
american idol was on television
arvo's still trends at the top of
people's minds
what's been the big youtube trend in the
last three months
squid game and i'm not seeing you
potentially jumping onto that trend to
see if you can establish yourself in
that area
so
in terms of your
audience i don't feel as if you found
your exact audience for the type of
content that you want to make so try to
determine
what would be your through line if i
watch a video on your channel and i
really enjoy it what am i going to watch
next that's going to keep me engaged
with your content
wow that is such a great uh a piece of
advice because you're right like i mean
american idol is was popular right but
it's not today so if you're gonna really
ride that train you've got to figure out
what is the thing and you're right rob i
mean squid games is taking what we did a
video about squid games because we
wanted to ride that trend as well
maybe if it was squid game auditions for
the masked singer
that seems to have more cultural
relevance right now if you were to maybe
produce such a a piece of content
i love that well let's jump into the
next review and this is with uh solar
simply solar power simply solar power
for beginners asked i'd love to know
about my uh subscriber to viewer ratio
or my view to subscriber ratio and my
overall theme and banner so first off um
i don't know if you did this on purpose
but i see yellow and solar and i'm like
that makes sense right the sun is yellow
or that's you know what we're told and
you see it it says um it says ask askly
solar so i don't know i think that's
maybe your brand name um so that's
that's fine for me with it being that
this is what you're doing for your
channel uh graphics um learning testing
and powering stuff so uh solar is
getting really huge right now and i'm
sure you are seeing a lot of different
types of questions coming in and again
i'm going to ask you to ride on some of
the trends and i see that you're
actually doing that with some of the
reviews that you're doing and when i go
up to this uh
bid iq plugin here i can actually click
on like the stats and i can see that um
that your downloads are down you've
posted nine videos and that's down 40
which means that you are posting a lot
of content um and so i would actually
recommend doing more that is quality
versus quantity nine videos um in a
month that's that's double what we think
that you technically should do being
that one video a week is great to do on
youtube if i go back here to
your channel i go to your videos and i
check out your most popular videos that
you did a year ago 14 000 views to your
5k subscribers this is telling you
something so on here i'm actually going
in just to see what is working what is
winning on your channel and what i'm
seeing winning on your channel
are these videos right here this whole
top row of videos in relation to your
subscriber count and i would say
here's what we say here at think media
make part twos if it's winning make a
part two so can you do a part two to my
first solar power system maybe it could
be updated after a year's use or
something like that or before you buy
those are really great because investing
in solar is an investment and so i would
make sure that you are going through and
if you see something that's winning make
a part two it's really critical to know
what works on your channel and because
you are still newer to um
to doing youtube here i can tell you
know a year ago uh uh four months ago so
i mean you're still in what i call the
experiment phase of youtube you're still
trying to figure out what videos work on
your channel and i'm seeing here i mean
this short video that's that's doing
okay one thousand three months ago and
it's got right here look at this vid iq
set a hundred percent of um likes on
that one so that's really good uh
happening on your channel so here's what
i would recommend is going through and
just looking at your top performing
videos the ones that are above your um
subscriber count and i would make part
twos to those videos now your question
also was is this a good ratio views to
subscribers and
here's the thing uh
subscribers while they matter they don't
actually
matter like they matter but it's that's
not actually what's bringing in the
revenue on your channel what brings in
the revenue on your channel is the views
and so i wouldn't even think about the
view and subscriber ratio i would just
be thinking how can i make winning
videos that are going to get the most
views and you can do that by answering
specific questions by making sure that
you're dialed into the right types of
videos that work for your channel and by
remaking videos that are already winning
on your channel so i hope that helps and
gives you some uh some tips for that one
rob who do you have next
i have and this is at the point of a
live stream where i have to apologize in
advance for my terrible channel name
pronunciation uh which i
i'm famed for getting wrong
jaron malk
i think i'm right there uh with the
conversation
uh this channel looks to me like they
are a technology channel and their
question just to remember what that was
was need some help prioritizing topics
that will help me
grow so
on face value
i'm getting a technology vibe except for
the two videos that you publish very
recently which are about golf
now just put yourself in the viewers um
frame of mind here they've been watching
you talk about the best wireless mic
best camera settings uh
something about a youtube studio i'm
getting that creative vibe oh now you're
going to play golf
uh i don't want to watch 18 minutes of
you playing golf i'm afraid can you put
that on another vlog channel please
possibly
i kind of do see that this throughout
your channel a little bit where by the
general focus seems to be
um creator tech but you just can't help
departing from that topic every so often
there's no one here does it matter what
game you play on twitch
again is that really creator focused if
that who that's who your target audience
is um i i'm gonna borrow um heather and
think media's phrase here um
success leaves clues and when i sort by
most popular i'm seeing that you tend to
have your strongest audience reaction
when you're making
content specifically about cameras uh
whether it be the camera on an iphone a
camera on a gopro to be able to use it
as a webcam that's quite a new one so
i'm imagining there's not many much
search competition there how to use a
sony a7c as a webcam so you know using
cameras as webcams that kind of seems to
be like a small little niche that you
found yourself in and that's how you can
start to build up a really strong
audience in that niche and then break
out into maybe what's the best
microphone to use in combination with
this camera or what's the best streaming
software to use with this particular
camera and so on so if you were to ask
me where your current strength is as a
creator it is uh camera
tools that help creators and then branch
out your content from there
that's a really good one
and you see this a lot too rob people
that should be i i feel guilty to this
sometimes too i just want to create and
so sometimes you start creating content
and you're like actually that's not
right for this channel and uh how do you
deal with that rob like in your own you
know when you want to make this content
for vet iq but you've got these really
awesome ideas that don't quite relate
do you find that to be a struggle also i
just slap myself in the face and say you
can't do that you can't do that yeah
it does come from experience
there is also a counter argument that uh
in order to sustain a creator's
i guess creative essence that you may
create one piece of content for
your audience and then one for you
i put it along the lines off if i want
to do something creative or fun
uh for a video i will plant a segment of
that i guess entertainment into
the content for example i just did a
video very recently which was about um
youtube shorts and they've now rolled it
out to a lot more countries
and i didn't know how to make that
entertaining and i thought it was going
to be a really boring video to make so i
tried to make a bit of a fun
sketch out of it whereby i was going to
try and read out as many of these 120
countries in a space of a youtube shot
in 60 seconds so there's going algeria
albania afghanistan and so on and so
forth and that kind of merged itself
into the video itself it provided a bit
more entertainment and that sustained
the creative side of my content but
there was still lots of value in there
for people who watch vid iq they want to
know how to monetize their channels so
yeah i think
sometimes you just have to accept that
the thumbnail and the title can't be
about what you want to make the content
about but that doesn't mean that you
can't start to inject your own style and
personality into the video itself
because that's how many creators find
their success they have that it factor
within the content
that's such great advice too because i
see that so much even in our content
creators uh you know there's four main
content creators on our channels and
each of us have our own little
personalities and we'd like to infuse
that into it but we're not making videos
that the subscribers didn't subscribe
for and that's a big piece of it so i
love that you did that um before we get
into the next review rob uh our sponsor
for today's video is actually did you
know rob it's vid iq that is for today
so uh right now if you go to vidiq.com
forward slash think you can actually get
a 30 day free plan so here's the thing
if you're starting a youtube channel
this is a must get like this is a must
get when you're starting a youtube
channel because they have some really
great features that are involved in it
and rob tell us a little bit about the
one where vidiq basically serves you up
on a platter videos that you should be
making
yeah so i can uh bring up my screen for
uh daily ideas actually
um once you make uh some content on your
channel and you've signed up to vid iq
it's gonna start to
figure out what your channel's about and
then make suggestions and ideas based
off of those ideas and i've kind of got
it in the tinder style right now where i
could swipe right or swipe left let's
just say how to get more views ah it's a
bit general i'll move on to the next one
how to get more views on your youtube
videos okay that's improving it's going
in the right direction but maybe i'll
choose something else new youtuber how
to get more views on youtube okay so now
we've got a bit of an idea manifesting
here uh is it given a fact that it's the
beginning of 2022 there's going to be a
lot of new people with those resolutions
they're going to start a new channel
maybe this is something i want to do a
bit more research on
that might not be my video title but
it's a genesis of a video idea and i can
click to do a bit more research see what
other creators are doing in this space
and how we might be able to leverage our
idea for our youtube channel i've only
shown three ideas here but we show
for um boost customers uh 50 video ideas
every single day that's over a thousand
ideas a month and surely from everything
that's been suggested here you can take
the top one percent of these and turn
them into video ideas that's hopefully
going to connect with your audience
because i mean if you just generally
look at all of these these right all in
both think media and vidiq's wheelhouse
secrets are becoming monetized on
youtube
some really interesting connotations
like how do you get monetized outside of
youtube you know not just ad revenue and
super chats but affiliate links and uh
brand deals and sponsorships so already
firing off the the ideas and neurons in
my head so that's just the daily ideas
tool but we have of course dozens more
besides this
so awesome and claire says daily ideas
is such an amazing feature and she loves
it i completely agree uh ian says vid iq
is the single most important tool for
youtube creators right answer yeah this
is exactly um this is you're so right if
you're jumping into youtube right now
you're new to youtube this is the tool
that you need so uh you can go to
vidiq.com forward slash think and that's
where you can get that free 30 days and
continue beyond there if you'd like to
let's jump into the next review that i
have and we've got uh slav make stuff
and uh slav actually just came back to
youtube so i want to welcome you back to
the community thanks for coming back in
um and i do i want to say also that if
you have taken a break from your channel
if you've felt like gosh i was producing
content i was doing really great i was
on a roll and then life happened right i
mean can we just say that over the last
couple years like life has happened and
that's okay um and you're coming back to
youtube i just want you to know that we
are here to support you and help you in
that but if you've taken
time off like more than a couple years
youtube's changed and so i want to make
sure that you know the new ways of
youtube success and we have a free class
that you can go to at
thinkmasterclass.com we're hosting a
free class tonight where you can learn
the new ways of youtube success because
youtube's changed over the last couple
years it's gone from checkers to playing
chess and so i want to make sure that
you are able to get uh the most relevant
information for what's working on
youtube right now but slav you've come
back it looks like you were on youtube
uh before you're coming back and you
want to know how to revive this channel
first off what a cool channel i was
peeking through some of your videos and
i mean i think it's so awesome when
people can create
and create like meta creation like
you're creating something and you're
videotaping videotaping oh my gosh that
did that just age me a little bit okay
you are actually recording um what
you're doing so really love uh the type
of content you were making before now if
you it looks like you came back and
you're doing the same type of content
and so a way to revive that we actually
just did a video over on think media if
you go over to our think media podcast
this channel here in the search bar up
here at the top if you type in the word
dead uh you're gonna get a um hour-long
video where we actually help you revive
your dead videos and your dead channel
so we can help you with those tips um on
there for you slav and basically here's
what we're saying you need to figure out
what's working now on youtube and you
need to go all in like can i simplify it
for you that's what we go over but if
you want more detail just uh right here
on this podcast channel you can go and
watch that video and we'll really help
you understand how to revive these old
videos and how to revive that channel
all right rob who do you have up next so
the next person we have lined up is um
mushy yo and their question
is not really anything to do about their
with their channel actually it's uh can
you review my on-screen presence please
uh so this isn't the easiest thing to do
on channel audits mainly because my
internet connection always seems to be
atrocious during live streams but it's
also difficult to um listen to the video
and then really really pay attention to
all of
the the style and presenting you're
doing but i was just flicking through it
in the background and it looks like
you're uh editing the video so you're
you're snapping to new scenes and doing
jump cuts which means that you're
probably taking out your ums and rs
which is fantastic
your voice sounded as if it was a a nice
relaxed cadence not too excited but at
the same time not too monotone and
boring so i would say for where you are
in your youtube journey uh with
just over a thousand subscribers
i think you're presenting an on-camera
presence is actually quite strong
of course
and i am
myself just like this we are sometimes
our own worst critics
when we are presenting in front of
camera i still feel at this point with
10 years of experience in 2000 videos
that i'm not good in front of camera but
then i have heather who probably who's
after live streams before giving me
wonderful praise about how
how good i am at presenting so sometimes
we just have to realize that we are our
own worst critics i think what you need
to concentrate a little bit more on is
actually the pitch on your channel
for example this video is about how to
print new pokemon snap on a nintendo
switch with a printer
the video is 13 minutes long and so what
i worry about there is if somebody's
searching for an answer to that question
does it really need 30 minutes to
explain how long that's going to take
maybe you could trim that down to four
or five minutes which means that the
edits are going to be even snappier
and you're going to reveal more value in
your content i feel as if that's a lower
hanging fruit here
because it feels like just through
experience and being in front of camera
you're slowly gaining that confidence
so good so good rob you're right i mean
rob can we just give it a round of
applause in the chat here rob you always
do such a great job live streaming i
love your advice i love the energy you
bring it actually helps me stay a little
more grounded because i drink way too
much coffee before we get on these live
streams and i get so excited um to help
people uh with their channels okay i'm
gonna jump into uh the next review that
i have and i'm excited because i am
reviewing uh ladies farm ladies farm and
your question was about your thumbnails
and a couple suggestions that i have
right off the bat when i see the channel
that you're producing um
is i think you are doing a great job
with the content so let me go back here
and preface this that says you said uh
that you feel like you're going at a
nice pace or am i struggling so you're
also trying to decide is this the right
pace um and you've been doing youtube
for six
months okay so here's the thing uh that
i love to preface all things youtube and
growth if you're just starting on
youtube
i want you to set realistic goals
realistic goals now of course there are
unicorns in the world that can come onto
youtube and skyrocket to a million views
but can i just let you in on a secret
youtube is a game of consistency if you
are consistent on youtube and you are
working at your craft and you're getting
one percent better every single time
then growth will be inevitable okay so i
just want to congratulate you for being
here for six months for making the
amount of videos that you have in six
months is amazing when i look at your
channel and i see that you are producing
content three days ago four days ago
four days ago four days ago 10 days ago
i mean you're cranking out some content
and you're farming i'm like you are my
hero this is amazing so a couple things
though that you asked for and that was
critique on your thumbnails and i'm
gonna be your coach here okay uh and i'm
gonna say that
when i look at a thumbnail like caramel
cheesecake i
want to eat cheesecake but if i can you
see where the cheesecake is it's like
it's like down in the little corner
almost by the time it's super tiny and
all i see is just the kitchen right i
want to see
the cheesecake i want it i want to like
see the thumbnail of the cheesecake and
that's what i want to click on so uh if
you're going to be doing um review or if
you're going to be cooking like chicken
stew or um or turkey rice soup
you actually don't need to be the
thumbnail and this is true for what we
do here at think media if we're doing a
camera review or we're doing a lighting
review people aren't coming to it for us
they want the camera and so we're going
to take the best
juiciest drippy crispy photo of the
actual camera why because that they are
sold on the camera first before they're
sold on us at think media so same thing
goes for you ladies farm is that you
should make uh thumbnails where you're
not in them and it actually looks like
maybe you're screen grabbing from those
uh from the the videos that you're
producing and so
you actually don't have to do that you
can just do it with the actual product
now here is what i'm going to give you
as homework because a coach gives good
homework right a coach gets you out
there on the field and makes you do the
jumping jacks and the push-ups and you
kind of want to curse me out a little
bit but you still love me
here's the thing
i need you to study food photography
you're like but heather i'm already
doing a farm and i'm you know making
this channel and i'm doing all the
things by myself here's the thing if you
want people to click on your videos your
thumbnails have to be awesome
they just do your titles and your
thumbnail has to be awesome especially
with the amount of content that's
happening on youtube right now if you
want to be in this game and you want to
win people's approval to be able to go
to the next level with you and whatever
that looks like they have to be able to
click on your thumbnail and it has to be
enticing so i want you to spend five ten
maybe 20 hours
going on youtube and studying food
photography and with that here's the
thing you don't need to buy new
equipment you can you you can do this
with your smartphone you could do this
with what you already have but it's
positioning your thumbnails to be
clickable and right now i'm seeing a lot
of busyness in the thumbnails i want you
to win so i want you to study that food
photography um also you are cranking out
content so
not that this is uh uh a bad thing i
would just caution you that since you've
been doing this for six months and
you're producing so much content at one
time i want you to think about the other
parts of youtube which are not just
producing the content but also building
the community so rather than maybe
uploading that second video how could
you spend that five ten twenty hours
that took you to create that video
spend it in the community in your
comments actually researching actually
going deeper in understanding youtube
and then produce that video that's super
high quality that gets you the views
that moves you forward on your mission
so i'm so excited for you uh this is a
really really great video a really great
channel and um
the cutest animals too i was like
looking in here at the cutest animals oh
my gosh look at look at these dogs
they're so cute look at these beagles oh
my goodness puppies on the farm i could
watch that all day long too i just i
love any farm content it's my favorite
thing ever
rob come on just give me ten more ten
more let's go
wow so much fun
i'm trying to get those reviews and i'm
watching my timer also and i'm like i'm
gonna get it all in rob
okay next channel i have lined up is
sketch my story
and this is one of those channels where
when you start to hear about the behind
the scenes you go wow that is true
commitment for at the moment not that
much youtube reward the question here is
i collab with other youtubers to animate
their best personal true stories
videos take 80 hours eight zero hours to
make i post every two to three thursdays
and i'm not getting much growth so it
feels like it's not worth it what to do
so first of all uh i commend you for the
incredible amount of effort and time
you're putting into your
youtube content
if we just look at the channel
as it is with about 12 um 12 videos
published
you're not in a bad place in terms of
what you might expect on youtube
already hit 100 subscribers some of your
videos are getting into triple digits
that's where i might expect a creator to
be at this point in their journey but of
course that doesn't factor in the
tremendous amount of time you're putting
into each video
now i am getting a little bit of deja vu
here i don't think i've just seen a
black cat walk across the screen i feel
as if we audited this channel on vid iq
as well because i seem to remember some
of these thumbnails in particular
this one where i looked at the thumbnail
and i thought huh as a viewer
just looking at the title and the
thumbnail
i really can't work out what i'm getting
into
for this video and i kind of feel i get
that impression on some more of these
ones as well like worst job ever and why
i snapped i don't know how captain
america ties into the story i'm sure you
can explain it but me as a person who's
not watched the video yet i feel as if
there's a bit of a disconnect between
thumbnails and titles so that is
something that certainly you can work on
and of course
you're already spending 80 hours on the
videos themselves
i'm guessing you've
probably can spend a bit more time on
maybe how the messaging works for the
thumbnails but also going back to what
um heather uh said before the intro
about perhaps
trying to
leverage influential people uh
you it would be in your topic but
because you're an animator you can
leverage
the power of any influential person in
the world and it looks as if right now
you're taking stories from actual um
famous people comedians for example and
telling their stories
what if you did almost like an
unauthorized animated story you take an
excerpt from somebody's biography and
you animate it
somebody really famous and popular
because again i asked the question while
i'm aware of some of these people
i'm not necessarily doing youtube
searches to find out a little bit more
about them so maybe
for where you are as a creator right now
in that people don't know you for your
animation they're more just stumbling
upon
interesting content when they search for
a particular person
maybe that's perhaps where you want to
focus uh your
strategy going forward especially if
you're spending so much time on each of
these videos because you're going to get
to a point soon where you're going to
burn out because 80 hours for a hundred
views it's just not sustainable is it
the one final thing i thought as well is
i don't know if you're already doing
this but each video is around about
three to four minutes i'm sure you have
some
quirky interesting entertaining
uh little snippets in each of those
videos
i think you could certainly take them
out repurpose content as a potential
youtube short
you might if i guess if you're if
they're landscape you can get away with
them being a square format or if you're
able to do a little bit of editing in a
vertical format to to maintain i guess
the structure of the video
so good rob so so good uh i love doing
these channel reviews um i hope you're
getting value in the comments right now
and i would love for you to hit that
like button i let's get the likes up a
little bit on this video that'd be
amazing and uh if you're watching this
on the replay so much value is in just
hearing the advice of other channels
because you can take that advice and
apply it directly to your own channel um
so there's so much value in that so a
question of the day would be to let us
know in the comments below do you like
these types of videos these channel
review videos and should we continue
them with rob from vid iq it's my
favorite thing over here on this channel
to do all right let's jump into the next
review that we have and i'm excited
because we're going to be reviewing
someone else who is jumping back
on
youtube jumping back on youtube and uh
doing great already 3 000 subscribers
over over 3 000 subscribers so
congratulations on that this is the
bearded i t dad what a cool branding
name and also i want to learn all of
your hacking skills that seems like a
lot of fun um and you had asked uh
you're really trying to grow your
channel after a year-long break so
welcome back to youtube and having some
success uh working with brands even uh
you're you're working with some brands
but you feel like you might be missing
something
uh
uh what is some what are some ways that
you can crush so one thing i just want
to say amazing job you're working with
brands at 3 000 subscribers
did you hear that family did you hear
that you don't need to have a hundred
thousand a million subscribers to work
with brands you just need to be focused
and that's exactly what the bearded i.t
dad is doing he's very focused he's not
even just talking i.t he's talking about
how to grow your career in the i.t field
so that even brings it down into people
who want to be in this field so a
question that you had really was about
the uh the videos that you're making and
since you're jumping back in here's a
tip for anyone who's been on youtube is
coming back to youtube has been making
videos for more than two years on
youtube if this is you've made videos
more than two years i want you to go to
your most popular videos and here's the
thing you can remake this video a day as
an i.t support specialist 32 000 views
okay success leaves clues i would remake
this video i'd remake this video the
path to becoming a self-taught i.t
support specialist now you might be
saying well yeah heather but i already
made that video or should i title it the
same yes you can title the video the
same you can reuse titles you can reuse
thumbnails but here's what's going to be
great about this remix of this video
is that you've been in the field longer
you have more advice you have post
pandemic advice you have people who have
left a job and are looking to work from
home as an i.t specialist so you have a
lot of ground that you can cover from
the last time you made this video three
years ago so redo this video go through
your best performing videos and remake
those videos or could you interview
someone
a big piece of uh of something in this
field would actually be to be
interviewing people who are in this
career field like are there authors are
there speakers are there popular people
in this field get them on your bearded
itdad show
you could start to use other people's
influence to be able to grow your
influence as well now you are definitely
coming back into the game i see that
with the views that you're getting on
your channel um and here's the thing
2022 information technology career goals
a minus a plus cc and this is this is a
lot
and um and i want it to be searchable so
if you're saying hey here's here are it
career goals or are these your goals
because if it's your goals then that
might not be
uh what other people are looking for
those are just your personal goals but
if you're saying how to become an i.t
professional from home
that's a video that people are probably
searching right now to figure out how to
land these types of jobs i see that you
are doing some brand things which is
great but i want to just revert you back
to answering specific questions people
are asking questions in the it field and
if you are wondering well yeah how do i
find those questions though heather
you can go to answerthepublic.com and
you can type in
itprofessional you can type in
itfield and you're going to get a ton of
questions another way you can do this is
by being a part of the community which i
definitely see that you are but go even
deeper are you inside of different
facebook groups are you in discords are
you on reddit are you seeing where the
conversation is around i.t and then
lastly there is a lot happening when it
comes to cyber security in our world
right now and so what are some trends
that you can ride what are some news
articles coming out about the um about
hacking and cyber security actually
yesterday i got a notice on my phone
that my that paypal
had been hacked i'm like what paypal is
hacked like
jump on that make a video and you could
bring knowledge to that space and you
can help people that are interested in
learning and growing in i.t so i hope
that helps and gives you a little bit
more advice on
how to grow and i'm excited that you're
back on youtube all right i want to let
everyone know that um submissions for
the channel reviews is closed we're
going to go through super chats that
were over 20 are at the front of the
line we're gonna get through as many as
we can until we get to the top of the
hour and uh we'll work through them as
fast as we can make sure you're
subscribed so that the next time we go
live and we do channel reviews you can
be here you can get that notification if
you uh press the bell and you'll get
notified when a live like this is
happening and also actually over on
rob's channel vid iq you guys are doing
channel audits every week right rob
are we endlessly uh we do um
two hours worth of channel audits every
single uh tuesday
um we try not to create any um
uh financial barriers to that it is
completely free but it does turn into a
bit of a bun fight we have hundreds of
submissions every single week but we
also have like many competitions as well
uh so do join us 11 a.m uh pt every
single tuesday
awesome and just a reminder that today's
show is actually brought to you by the
iq that's why we're joined by rob from
vid iq and you can get 30 days of a free
trial with the amazing software that
plugs right into your youtube channel
gives you all these really fun stats and
helps you figure out what videos you
should make so you can win on youtube
this year you can get that at vidiq.com
forward slash think all right rob who do
you have up next this channel i will
definitely pronounce wrong i it's maya
that's what i'm going with
first of all congratulations on 84 000
subscribers and what looks to be a very
healthy community you're getting tens of
thousands of views comfortably each
video that's fantastic the question they
have for us is um please could you let
me know what your thoughts are on the
thumbnails titles
and on the channel overall
now this is a tricky one this because
when i look at these thumbnails
i think wow there is a lot going on
it's almost like a mosaic of different
images in the thumbnails the text is
sometimes tiny difficult to read
different fonts
this is hard work for me to try and
decode but having said that when i look
at other day in the life channels which
i think this is
going in that direction the thumbnails
are of a
similar style we've
kind of almost like organized chaos look
to them
so i think in terms of how your
thumbnails fit the demographic i think
you're in the right place
you could try and simplify the
thumbnails a little bit uh or maybe
outsource it to see if somebody could
have a fresh perspective but those are i
would say things that you want to test
because i wouldn't be surprised if what
happens with your audience is that they
just see a
thumbnail
that they they know a little bit they
know it's you and they don't really look
at the thumbnail of a title actually
they just click on it because they
because they're familiar with your
content but then having said that
channel overall
it looks to me like you have your most
success when you are covering
videos which are about your school
routine or going to school i see a quite
significant increase in view counts when
you make that sort of content so that is
your foundation but i think you have
license to explore these other avenues
like your i see you here a video that
did straight to curly
hair wash but
18 000 views that looks like it's one of
the um the worst performers for you but
it's still very very strong in relation
to your subscriber
size it feels as if you have a real core
community lots of return viewers which
is fantastic so my question is like what
do you do next and i think there's three
things i'm looking at here
first of all your community tab you're
not using that very much right now and i
feel as if you could engage with your
audience a little bit more here
especially with voting polls you could
literally ask your audience what type of
content do you prefer or what would you
like me to make next or you can like
have teaser thumbnails and whatnot for
your future videos
i did quickly scroll down your channel
and i'm not seeing any live streams so
maybe this is an avenue to get into
where you're actually directly
interacting with your audience just like
we are here and you can maybe build up a
community where uh you're taking
questions maybe through super chats or
you're bringing people onto the live
stream and having conversations
and then here's the next thing this is
probably a big thing to suggest but just
hear me out i think you publish content
two or three times a week
what if you went daily
but
in order to be able to sustain that
this might be the point where you
outsource perhaps the editing so you can
just focus on all of the filming and
then you send that off to an editor and
that allows you to do daily content
because i feel as if this is the type of
audience that wants to check in with you
every single day but do you have a
capacity to do that
i wish you all of the best and
congratulations in advance on that
silver play button which is probably
heading your way uh in the next couple
of months
yep that's what i was gonna say rob like
almost to a hundred thousand is such a
cool milestone to get to
and um yeah really great and i was like
isn't it cool rob to see what are the
videos that pop off like the ones that
start to go more viral it's it's so much
about making videos so that you can see
what is working for your audience and
then building that community to get more
and more feedback of the right videos to
make yeah absolutely absolutely
all right we're gonna get to a few more
of our channel reviews and i'm excited
because i'm going to review natalie
heels and natalie i want to thank you
for being a part of the think media
community um and for being a part of
what we're doing here and
congratulations for starting your
youtube channel i see that you've been
creating content um for about five
months and looks like you got started
with uh jumping right into youtube
shorts and then starting to create some
more long form content i love that i can
see the soothing branding on your
channel and i think you're doing a
really great job with your thumbnails
these are definitely standing out and
i'm i'm loving that you're doing um like
this is a really good thumbnail uh of
what you are
teaching inside of your videos now you
are uh worried that you're just not
seeming to grow and you don't know why
so here's what i like to do um i've got
the vid iq plugin right here and i can
click that stats button and natalie
you're growing do you see this you grew
by 5
000 views in the last 30 days 5 000
people clicked on your videos in the
last 30 days you grew by a hundred
subscribers in the last 30 days and i
can see that that is credited to the
videos that you are posting you posted
10 videos in the last month so
i want to debunk the fact that you're
not growing and i don't want you to
speak that over yourself you are growing
you're just not growing as quickly as
you would like to so a couple things um
that i would suggest for the videos um
is i want to make sure you're picking
the right topics or the right video
topic because i think the titlings um
the titling is good the uh the
thumbnails are good we need to go more
topical so some research that i want you
to do natalie is i want you to find
three other channels who are further
along than you and i want you to go and
i want you to hit the sort button and
hit most popular
when you hit most popular it's going to
bring up your competition's most popular
videos now this is not a time to compare
yourself okay just
hear me this is what will happen you'll
click on it you're like dang it you're
doing so much better than me no no
that's not what we're doing we're gonna
click on it because we just need to
study what people are interested in and
what's great is that you're in a proven
market and so all we need to do is
figure out the videos that people are
clicking on you can watch those videos
if you'd like to but what i would
suggest is taking the titles that are
winning the topic that is winning and
maybe the thumbnail design that is
winning and applying that to your
channel now again this is not comparison
and this isn't copying this is actually
saying i'm going to do market research
to see what people are interested in so
that i can create videos just like that
so your homework is to go find three
other channels to study so that you can
see how you can uh grow in this um space
now uh
movement is massage uh i don't know if
that's a technique of massage so it's
explanation and introduction to massage
at home um i don't know i'm i would say
that that i want you to pick topics that
are maybe a little bit more broad than
that um that might be a piece of what
you're doing maybe movement is massage
is a type of massage but hitting this
like plantar fasciitis i know that is a
common problem um that people have so
you're headed on the right journey and
you're five months into this journey
but i want you to to make goals that
make sense so maybe your first goal is
to get that 1000 subscribers and reverse
engineering those other channels is
going to help you choose the right
videos by downloading the vid iq 30 day
free trial where you can start to get
those video ideas it's going to help you
move forward on your journey on youtube
so natalie thanks for being a part of
what we're doing here
and rob who do you have up next could
you just send me a further heather no
something really interesting in that
channel are you able do you still have
it up i got it so the the science of and
this is how much of a lemon i am well
the science of
p-s-a-r-o-a-c part two yeah okay so
whatever that is i'm really interested
in
the decision made by the creator there
because
you
you say yourself at think media success
leaves clues make part two
and
they've done that
but
it looks as if the videos were both
released possibly exactly the same time
like
release the same
even at the same time or like maybe a
couple of hours afterwards and
i always try and preach that if you are
going to make follow-up content to
something never try and make it as a
part two three four or five because it
needs so much more investment from that
viewer to move from one part to the next
or if they encounter part two first
does that mean i have to go and try and
find part one so in just in terms of the
titling of the messaging on the
thumbnails
by all means the videos can follow on
from each other but i think in order to
get somebody into the piece of content
they need to phrase that a little
differently um
like it could be something along the
lines of the science of this an
introduction and then a science of the
science of this uh
i don't know what i can't think of
exactly how you phrase it but i'm sure
you can see where i'm going with this
part numbers
traditionally
don't seem to do videos any favor favors
on youtube
yeah and she said that it's actually a
part of a course that she has
and um
remembering that people aren't searching
for that so that is when you have part
two there another piece of that also is
it's it's wasted letters to the amount
that people can read so you could you
don't even have to title it the science
of um maybe it's like understanding this
muscle or something like that yeah you
don't even have to title it
you don't have to have to title it what
it is if that makes sense you can really
make it a juicy title to get the click
through and then natalie what you do is
you say at the very beginning in your
hook you give a hook for your video and
then you say and this is part of a
six part series and i'll make sure to
link all those uh videos down below so
if you didn't watch the previous ones
don't worry you can go back and watch
those so that it gives them that
language that this is a part of an
entire series
sorry for side tracking there heather i
just sounded really interested in those
two videos that were right next to each
other in terms of when they were
published really right so the channel
i'm looking at now is learn share photo
of video and actually heather i probably
would appreciate some of your input on
this one because the question is
how do i turn my videos into a course
for an additional stream of income and i
know you think media have done
phenomenal jobs of this but maybe i'll
start off with this one they have
32 000 subscribers which is fantastic
but what i'm seeing is that as an
education channel you have that real
problem of getting viewers to stick on
your content and it may be because
people search for your content they find
an answer
and then they move on
my guess is from your channel if i
search by most popular you're probably
getting the majority of your views from
these most popular videos and these most
popular videos are certainly about
photoshop so that is your super power
now what tends to be the case more often
than not is that people actually put
courses on their youtube channels
without realizing it but they just put
it in like tons of different videos over
the course of eight months like i'm sure
if if i looked at vidi the vid iq
channel we could probably have a course
for how to start your youtube channel
but it's just intermingled with tons of
other courses
so you've probably already got the
material there to start creating a
course uh if i just click by s uh
trending i think what this tool will do
is tell us which videos are getting the
most views per hour if it's gonna work
let me just try that one more time
doesn't seem to want to work today which
is a shame but anyway i'm guessing just
going back to the videos your most
popular ones are where you're strongest
as an educator
so how do you turn it into a course and
how do you market it i think that's
where i'm gonna pitch it off to heather
for the experience here of how think
media have done it
yeah and rob you actually hit on a
little bit of that too was that you've
probably put the pieces out there
they're just not in the right order or
in the right structure to be able to
consume it to make it a course so
i actually have a video that's coming
out uh here on the channel um that's in
partnership with a amazing course
hosting platform called thinkific and uh
the reason i wanted to partner with
thinkific was because they're helping
creators like you uh actually figure out
their courses like what should you make
your course about and here's the thing
about online courses um people can
consume free content anytime they want
but if someone wants an outcome right
people buy outcomes people buy solutions
and so if someone wants a particular
solution and you have the steps one
through ten to get to that particular
outcome that is something you can take
and package and sell and even though you
might have put it out on your channel
for free
if it's not in the right order in the
right context in the right way that
would teach someone to go from a to z
and get this specific outcome like when
you finish this course you will know how
to
x y and z uh
that is when you decide to um to package
your knowledge into a framework so that
someone can actually get that outcome
now you might have experimented with
this already by doing free tutorials and
things like that on your channel you can
repackage that tutorial that's free on
your channel add more to it maybe
there's downloads maybe there's a
community involved maybe you add in
three more steps that you didn't use on
your video and you then package that
into a course and actually over on our
think media channel we interviewed our
friend
uh and she actually teaches you how to
make your own e-course um and we go into
detail there's lots of different ones on
here how to launch your digital product
in one day right here's the video i want
you to watch this is how to launch a
what's called a tiny offer um and in
this one ally actually goes through oh
here's hulu okay uh ali actually goes
through um how to decide what content
you should make so she walks you through
the systems and how to actually convert
sales off of youtube but what you should
actually be making a course about so as
you are moving through um the idea of
course creation definitely check out our
video that we have here in partnership
with thinkific go to thinkific also
because if you uh if you sign up for
thinkific as your coast horse
course hosting platform they actually
have an entire series dedicated to
youtubers which i think is so cool rob
that that that these courses are
actually seeing that content creators
can make
really great money off of it and so
they're actually helping you figure out
the marketing behind it as a youtuber so
uh how you do it is um that in that
shell and make sure to check out that
video uh that'll lead you down the
course of success um for the 10 steps to
creating an online course
thank you for saving my bacon there
so much happening i get really uh i get
really into the idea of course creation
too because it is what allowed me
personally to get to financial freedom
as a youtuber it wasn't the views that
were happening on the channel those are
great but it was the it was what we were
able to create off of youtube it was the
the knowledge we were able to package
off of youtube where we were able to use
youtube as the marketing arm into our
actual
business and that is something that i
hope course or content creators can see
as to why this is such a critical thing
to do grow to grow your youtube channel
you can then market to people to go
deeper into the things that you're doing
so i'm excited for what he's going to be
creating and it looks like i've got one
more i can get to today if your channel
was not reviewed today don't worry uh we
will be here again reviewing channels
and as well as over on vid iq um you can
go over there and rob reviews channels
all the time uh so you can jump in the
queue over on vidiq's
channel and i'm gonna bring up uh we've
got let me bring up magnify money is
going to be the one that i'm doing today
magnifymoney congratulations you are
already at 20 000 subscribers can i just
say the financial
industry is winning on youtube it's
insane what i'm seeing happening in the
financial world with people that are
able to create great content on youtube
about that my friend erica kohlberg has
been blowing up in the financial space
in in the law space um all about just
helping people on youtube so i'm excited
that you're helping people uh with a
problem which is figuring out how to
manage their money and your question was
how can i improve my titles and
thumbnails to increase youtube browse
exposure and increase potential growth
so um a couple things here uh i
definitely see the strategy that you
have with your thumbnails when i just
look at them they're very um
they have a lot of animation to them
like i can tell there's a lot of
animation in your face there's a lot of
things happening and i want to
encourage you to watch the video that
nolan did on think media where he
learned an insight from netflix and by
watching that video it's going to help
you go deeper into the psychology
of of
what is happening on youtube um in
relation to netflix and then the second
one to watch is the video about um the
insider
secrets we learned from a youtube
employee so both of those videos i think
can help you so
um your
titles is the american express platinum
card still worth it in 2022 that is a
great
question and you're answering it which
is a great thing to do uh top five
millionaire habits that have changed my
life
that's going to be a harder one to go
into because you're going into
millionaire habits and and mindset is
not the easiest ones to create videos
around so how to earn your first 1 000
with crypto i think this video is going
to do great that's a really great uh
um video title that's happening but if
we go again into your most popular
videos
you have a video that's almost at a
hundred thousand views
top five best bank accounts of 2021.
let's remake that video and put 2022 on
it as well and maybe the actual bank
accounts have changed right um i would
remake this video
crime credit builder card review so now
that you've done it once can you do it
again and explain even more i like that
you're going on the capital uh capital
one 360. i would go deeper into that so
capital
one 360. look at all these videos you
could make with that let me zoom in a
little bit here this is just going into
the search of what people are asking a
checking account savings account debit
card shrinking funds crediting debit
card checking review see all of these
you can ride the wave of that capital
one 360 when i say success leaves clues
i mean these are great video options to
be making on there um when i think about
uh what is this chime credit builder i
would actually do another review on them
and see if there's more content that you
create can be creating from these
winning videos you're seeing a theme
here i hope in the reviews that we've
done today you're seeing a consistent
theme
rob success leaves clues right it
definitely does uh i want to say as well
what an what a fantastic channel name uh
very memorable i'm not gonna forget that
um
in a hurry um
my thoughts would be uh within your
space
what are people really interested in
how much i can earn how much i could
potentially lose how much can i save
dollar amounts on thumbnails test that a
little bit more as well and i love the
way that the credit is using very
specific questions and answers on their
thumbnails
my question but this is a little bit of
a
risky area to play here but
can you draw out a more of an emotional
um
fear concern goal motivation of the
viewer like let's say
just as an example it might be something
along the lines of terrible credit
rating try this so you're targeting a
specific viewer who has issues getting
credit cards this is how you may be able
to solve it um so maybe something along
those lines along with all of the
exceptional titling structure that
you're already using you're using verses
you're using how-to titling and
listicles i think that's all great but
maybe some emotional pull as well is
worth experimenting with
yeah and i would also say um your videos
are well produced i mean
well i'm going into ads because i
well here we go i should i should
upgrade um rob look at this
this is a beautifully produced show i
want i want that studio oh wow
cameras
yeah multiple cameras the zooming in i
mean
this is a beautifully produced show
i don't know if that's on a slider he's
got the books behind him that's a great
in affiliation
um
yeah
and and oh you know what else too when
i'm talking about that uh uh riding the
wave of people who are famous dave
ramsey's got a new book coming out and
you know what when people have books
coming out they love to be on shows and
you are at 20 000 subscribers on youtube
but if you reached out to his team you
might be able to get an interview so
that would be a really cool uh uh way
also to
growth hack your channel for what you're
doing but this is
i mean i want this this is beautiful
yeah really great job production levels
are off the charts i would be um
definitely taking a look at your average
view duration and just seeing if um
because it looks as if your production
values are very high um obviously we
haven't really paid attention to the
content that much are you delivering
value in that content and if the answer
is no
then perhaps you need to edit a little
even more ruthlessly or
or maybe uh think about a slightly
different way of presenting the
information because
just like
when you look at all of the first
impressions the channel the thumbnails
the titles the production quality
this i see this channel primed for
success in 2022. it seems
it seems impossible not to
have a channel a hundred thousand
subscribers by this time next year
yeah definitely and you know the use of
what you're doing in the tags too just
coming down here to see like
you're doing great in this also um and
what's cool is you can like click on
this and you're going to get other ideas
from vid iq so um be using the different
tools that are available too to go
deeper into what is available so
uh well rob i want to thank you so much
for being on the think media podcast on
the youtube made simple show today
always a pleasure to have you on what
encouragement do you have rob to people
who are going to be starting their
channel in 2022
be
relentless
that's it
i'm just going to keep it i'm just going
to keep it nice and simple for once i
love it
never give up uh the chances are like
i'm thinking about animation channel you
know you're probably
you're currently at this flat line and
you're probably about here and you want
to and and imagine if you quit now but
then in two months
one of the videos takes off and i feel
as if that channel certainly has the
potential to do it
and it's just a case of
whenever something doesn't happen that
you expect to happen on youtube because
i'm going everything to a rambling
soliloquy now it dusts yourself off you
stand up and you go again and you keep
going until you figure it out and you
know who your audience is and how to
pitch your videos to them be relentless
i should hashtag that you should that
should be a new shirt rob you're always
good with the shirt so it should be a
new shirt well thanks for being on today
rob and if you like this video make sure
to give it a like because that just you
know sends warm vibes to me when i know
that you like videos like this if your
channel didn't get reviewed today don't
worry if you subscribe and hit the
notification button you'll be notified
of the next time that we do channel
reviews and as always we are so excited
that you are a part of the think media
family and i want to leave you with this
uh little ad at the end did you see
thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
off our brand new
youtube made simple course bundle get
over 1 900
worth of our best courses tools
templates and more just go to
thinkmediasale.com